media darling and america's top
doctor anthony fauci is playing some
serious defense
after a trove of emails blew a huge hole
and is already shrinking credibility
they reveal his relationship with the
wuhan lab that is facing new scrutiny
in the global pandemic that has killed
millions
senator rand paul claims fauci lied to
america about that lab potentially doing
research
that could make viruses more deadly
dr fauci still denies it to this day but
in his private emails
he puts in the subject line urgent we
must discuss this gain of function
research
so he knows it's gain of function and he
needs to be pinned down on this
i don't think that uh having trust of
chinese scientists with gain and
function research
was very wise in fact it was so naive
that we shouldn't have dr fauci in a
position
of advising the u.s the world or anybody
else because he's so
shown such poor making for some reason
dr
fauci refuses to call out china
the idea i think is quite far-fetched
that the chinese deliberately engineered
something so that they could kill
themselves
as well as other people i mean obviously
you want
openness and cooperation one of the ways
you can get it
is don't be accusatory
and the white house is standing by
fouchy despite the email controversy
we'll let him speak for himself and he's
been an undeniable asset
in our country's pandemic response but
it's obviously not
that advantageous for me to relitigate
the substance of emails from 17 months
ago
jesse don't be accusatory he should have
had a secret server in his basement
and he just could have wiped it like
crooked these emails are bad i mean he's
on the record of supporting gain of
function he funded gain a function
in wuhan he knew they were doing gain a
function in wuhan
they had scientists emailing him this
thing looks engineered
and then now he's on email scrambling to
see if his fingerprints are
on gain of function that's not my
opinion those are the facts
and vanity fair came out with a big
expose blowing the lid off the cover-up
u.s government telling investigators
don't look into this because u.s money
went into this lab
manpower know-how money
went into this lab that ended up killing
three and a half million people this is
bigger than 9 11. this is bigger than
january 6.
dare i say greg this might be worse not
watergate
and the media is complicit in the
cover-up they admitted it
and here's why the democrats needed
fauci so they could brand themselves as
pro-science
they needed fouchy to lock everything
down so they could loosen the state
election laws
and do the mass mail out of ballots and
they needed vouching to point the finger
away from china and at trump so they
could divide the country
for the election you take fauci out of
the picture
it's like taking a jenga block out the
whole thing
crumbles well they get to the bottom of
it though
biden and co jessica they've got what
they're looking into it
i absolutely think that they will i
think the fact that we have moved
away from the who already looked into it
to we're going to look into it ourselves
and there's bipartisan support for that
i see no reason
that president biden would stop that in
any way and dr fauci is supportive of
that as well
to jesse's point well first i love that
now hillary isn't even hillary she's
just crooked i assume
we've dropped her birth name yes second
of all
you've said that the whole jenga tower
falls which included the mail-in ballots
which i believe means you're alleging
that the election was fraudulent
no i'm saying it helped loosen the state
election laws because everybody had to
stay home during the lockdown you didn't
need to lock everybody down
you just needed to isolate the elderly
the rest of the country could have gone
about their business
and fauci was warned to do this by
scientists
we saw the emails and he ignored it well
dr waters has spoken on that
yes he has we'll come back to that but
from looking at the emails i
i think that some of it definitely
doesn't look fantastic
but he was on with john berman we showed
a little bit of it and he talked about
that email in february
and he clarified that obviously if he
had known what they had known
in april in may that he would have told
sylvia matthews burwell to wear a mask
on a flight and that we were getting new
information from the scientific
community as it went along but i totally
agree so science wasn't settled
no it wasn't oh so like global warming's
not settled
no global warming oh that's subtle but
this science isn't stop playing a game
with me but anyway
but janet just on the surface the most
reasonable explanation was gee whiz
there's a virology lab right in
wuhan while the horseshoe bats
lived in caves hundreds of miles away
but instead the media
and tony fauci bent over backwards to
lean on a hypothesis that wasn't as
reasonable and logical as oh it came out
of a lab that had safety problems
because xi jinping talked about it
well and that gets back to this vanity
fair article that jesse was talking
about
it makes some explosive allegations that
people within the state department were
actively telling people
shut it down don't dig there don't go
there because you're going to open a
pandora's box
you heard dr fauci again today saying we
have to be careful with china because we
need to be able to cooperate with them
it's been over a year they haven't
exactly been transparent with the who or
anyone else
i'm aw listen digging i like you grew up
in the south we believe you get more
flies with honey but when the flies are
full of committing
human rights atrocities and not giving
you any information it's time to get rid
of the honey and maybe go with some
tabasco or something maybe a little bit
stronger yeah the communist party greg
if they're uh talking and breathing
they're lying yeah you know the
this is the funniest part of the story
is they they mentioned the phrase
pandora's box
that lab literally is a pandora's box
they opened it it got out so the idea
like i
i always wonder how many investigations
are stopped when somebody says oh that's
a pandora's box it's like
maybe you should open the pandora's box
and see what's going on in there
look we talked about this last week one
of the reasons why
they wanted to blame the wet markets
it's not just because
of the lab it's because we're involved
in the lab we have
money there we were thinking you know
originally it's the chinese
they're protecting themselves no we're
actually trying to protect ourselves
because we if we're invest i mean these
are our experts these are our scientists
if this was consider if this were the
plot to a movie right
scientists in government engage in
highly controversial
and risky uh research two there's an
accident nobody's saying that this was
deliberate
uh fauci kind of blends that together so
this research
accidentally is unleashed into the
public a dangerous pathogen right
the scientists and the experts and the
politicians scramble to protect their
vital research
and cover up the plausible cause if that
were that's a michael crichton movie
it's but it's not it's real and i think
that's why you have to have an
investigation
is fouchy the villain in this i i just
think he's an
overly diplomatic bureaucrat the real
villain to me
is the media and the democrats a for
pushing impeachment
exactly exactly as the virus was
exploding
countless lives were lost because they
hated trump and number two
labeling anybody a racist who dared to
criticize
china that that helped that that steered
the debate
towards something totally stupid like a
pangolin which still sounds like a
musical instrument i wouldn't want to
play
but it does have scales oh whoa
brains i don't i i would laugh
but i'm in all of that but just before
we go
well biden because to get to the bottom
of this
joe biden and company all the liberals
will have to admit
trump was right yeah they can't do that
they can't do that
also there's a lot of money at stake if
there's going to be lawsuits
you can't sue china if it's the lab you
gotta sue china and america
yeah and the funding started during the
obama biden administration
we need to we need to impose
impeach obama that is possible right
good luck for this yeah good luck with
that jessica we're going to impeach
obama
well we're going to go to break and then
we're going to talk about the
feasibility of that happening
before we go to break though i'm going
to add that i think any medicare for all
any government-run health care is now
dead
because you look at tony fauci and who
would want some
you know spotlight-seeking power-hungry
career bureaucrat
who's some fame floozy deciding who gets
to live
people without insurance would still
prefer that no they wouldn't
no that's the emergency room jessica
please we all have health care in this
country hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else